I want to talk about 2024 and 2024's
possible Republican contenders I'm not
talking about Donald Trump here Donald
Trump is running at least for now unless
he drops out uh I'm talking about the
other possible contenders and Fox
Business and actually Fox News in
general has regularly been putting up
images like the one we're putting up now
this one is called possible Republican
candidates in 2024 and indeed Donald
Trump isn't on that list because Trump
is not a possible candidate he is a
candidate the folks listed include
former vice president Mike Pence current
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis Virginia
governor Glenn Younkin Larry Hogan ASA
Hutchinson Senator Tim Scott Mike Pompeo
Nikki Haley and Chris Christie and
what's really interesting about this
list is that it's a really scary list
and I thought let's just talk a little
bit about the people that are sort of
considered contenders to be Republican
uh uh uh Presidential nominee at least
hypothetically and think through how
extreme the party has gotten at the end
of the segment I'll tell you who would
be my choice if I wanted to to to limit
damage to the country and I'll tell you
in a moment
um you've got Mike Pence Mike Pence
wildly against abortion skeptical about
climate change has a history of opposing
LGBT rights wants to Build That Wall
with Mexico has been against Obamacare
never mind stronger Health Care programs
than Obamacare seems very interested in
religion more and more officially
playing a role in civil government and
also just on a personal level
is kind of a kind of a [ __ ] in the
sense that even though Trump's
supporters were calling for him to be
hanged he still doesn't totally denounce
Trump although he kind of has and he
said I think we'll have better
candidates or whatever it's just a guy
who is both spineless and has some of
the worst political views that's one
alternative to Trump for the Republican
Party okay it's pretty bad then you've
got Ron DeSantis Ron DeSantis whose
record is Florida Governor is one of
regularly signing into law bills that
restrict abortion in Florida loves
restricting abortion
um regularly weakens gun laws in Florida
at every opportunity supported repealing
the Affordable Care Act has a horrible
environmental record in Florida loves
fossil fuels opportunities to use more
fossil fuels and make it easier to use
fossil fuels DeSantis loves it and in
addition to that DeSantis
is arguably more competent than Trump
and as a result could be extraordinarily
more dangerous if he became the
president of the United States then
you've got arguably one of the slightly
less extreme people on the list Larry
Hogan but you look at his record and
it's horrifying against abortion as most
of these people are against the
Affordable Care Act tried to repeal the
Affordable Care Act supports the oil and
gas industry backwards just totally
backwards and we're supposed to see him
as less extreme to pick a senator Tim
Scott from South Carolina Tim Scott
against abortion wants to restrict
access to abortion is against any gun
safety regulation supports every tax cut
that's proposed skeptical about climate
science even though he doesn't actually
know anything about it so I could go on
and on and on it's an insane list of
people now if I look at the list and you
said to me David and this is something
that probably would bring tears to your
eyes if you came to me and said David
it's going to be one of the people on
this list tears
if you knew
it was going to be one of these people
who defeat the Democrat who would you
choose the to me it seems clear that
it's Chris Christie
and I'm glad to hear from other people
and see your opinions but when I look at
this list Pence DeSantis young and Hogan
Hutchinson Scott Pompeo Haley Christie
and then Trump who has already declared
to me it's Chris Christie Chris Christie
is
a smart guy in a way that a lot of these
other people aren't maybe DeSantis but
but you know like Pence and uh young
Christy is a smart guy former prosecutor
more moderate socially to some degree
because of his experience as governor
and a Northeastern Governor understands
compromise and working across the aisle
in a way that some of these other people
do now I know people write to me and say
David Christie's insane what are you
talking about remember it's if one of
these people was going to be the next
president I think I'm choosing Chris
Christie and
um I'm interested to hear from others
but it's shaping up to be a pretty scary
list now fortunately or unfortunately I
don't know you know names like Don Jr
sometimes thrown around they're not
showing up on this list at least not yet
and I think we should probably be happy
about that
did you know that half of Americans are
deficient in vitamin A vitamin C and
magnesium most Americans are deficient
in vitamin D I take vitamin D during the
winter it is sometimes difficult to eat
exactly the right amount of each food to
get exactly what you need I just make my
life simpler with ag1 by athletic Greens
in the morning one scoop of ag1 I get
the entire day's worth of 75 high
quality vitamins minerals and Whole Food
sourced ingredients it's what I want
it's no more it's no less it's not
making any outlandish claims it's just
an easy sustainable routine I've tried
different ways of taking vitamins ag1 is
cheaper it's quicker it's tastier I'm
not fumbling around with different
capsules it tastes great to drink
straight with water sometimes I'll put
it in a smoothie or Shake it's simple
it's something easy you can do going
into the new year staying properly
nourished athletic greens is giving my
audience a free year supply of vitamin D
I take that every day in Winter plus
you'll get five free travel packs of ag1
go to athleticgreens.com Pacman the link
is down below